yeah their book is very wise um and it
it talks about the whole patient
approach U it does have uh the 3ps
people place and purpose and it goes
into things that have been constructive
that when and what's good too is you're
honest you're like initially you were
like that works and you're like yeah it
does work so it it's things like um
supportive grandmas where they're
they're like reaching out to Friendship
bench yeah that's right yeah the
Friendship bench I was like that works
and you talk about how the treatment is
is a small fraction of uh the the
problem um even though even that's not
you know happening all the time
obviously uh and that there are all of
these things around the patient the
environment their ability to feel like
there's a reason to wake up in the
morning you know like get out and do
things you know and when you think about
it's like oh that seems pretty obvious
but uh but then that's not the way our
sick care system approaches things like
you say they go in and be like oh you
you got acute symptoms let me try and
zap those symptoms and then you like put
them back into whatever the heck
environment and hope for the best and uh
and Shockers it's not very effective
yeah I was at a meeting yesterday where
somebody when I said we don't have a
mental health care System he said of
course we have a system we have exactly
a system it's not broken he said it
works exactly the way it was set up to
work but just to be totally
dysfunctional it's actually you know
it's just it's incentivizing all the
wrong things and um and I think that's
that's right I think we could fix this
simply by starting to move the money
towards what the things we want the
other thing you mentioned this before
Andrew and it's often not clear to
people who aren't directly involved in
this field but if you have a loved one
with severe mental illness they're not
looking for care often uh they don't may
they may not even think that they're
sick they may deny being ill and that's
such a huge challenge because it throws
you into this problem that I write about
in The Book of involuntary treatment and
uh you know in America we don't like to
talk about this but for someone who has
dementia or sometimes for young children
who are too young to be able to choose
that they actually need to have blood
drawn to get a diagnosis or or for
someone with psychosis who says look um
yeah I'm I'm telling you there really
are aliens who are tracking my brain
waves and you just can't hear them but I
can and so I'm right and you're wrong um
those are people who may need to be
treated um in spite of their wishes and
we've been very loathed to do that um
and it's one of the reasons why in
California we have so many people living
under bridges and eating out of
dumpsters because we don't want to we
don't want to confront them and say look
you're sick and you need to be the
compassionate thing here is to help you
even though you may not want the help
what we're doing is allowing people to
die with their rights on and the
governor has finally said maybe that's
not the most compassionate thing maybe
we need to to actually mandate treatment
and we also need to mandate that the
counties provide the treatment for
people who may not be knocking on their
door but who were living under their
Bridges I I yeah I I I think it's I
don't think it's compassionate just to
let someone die under the bridge uh you
know I don't think it's compassionate to
be uh stepping over people who are
clearly in in need of help as is
happening in a a lot of places uh I
think it's just um I me you described as
a reluctance to confront um there are
various failures really institutional
failures uh and then people suffer as a
result including people who could use um
some help uh and you your book really
makes a very powerful case like look we
don't allow this for diabetes or any
other type of illness like what the heck
are you know why are we treating this so
differently yeah I think I think the
reason we do is we confuse illness and
identity and it's an easy mistake to
make as I write about in the book you
know these are people who have made that
mistake for themselves they may think
that schizophrenia is who they are and
what we're doing here when we allow
someone to stay under the bridge is
we're listening to their illness and not
paying attention to their identity and
you know and maybe only 2% of that
person is the part that's going to
recover it's it but but it's still that
2% that you've got to focus on the part
of that person that is not ill and it's
I mean for the
people who do this um and to spend the
time um trying to help those under a
bridge someplace and here where I live
in the Bay Area we have thousands and
thousands of people in this situation um
what you learn is they don't really want
to be living this way this isn't a
choice this isn't what they want to do
they're frightened um and they're
frightened because of the voices and and
they're frightened to go someplace where
they won't they don't know what's going
to happen to them uh and so it's it it's
it's kind of Unthinkable that we have
allowed their illness to
become the part of them that we are
listening to instead of understanding
that there's a
person behind that illness who's
ultimately going to Triumph if they get
the right care but who um just doesn't
have the strength to do it by themselves
and so it does come down to compassion
and thinking about what is the most
compassionate issue but I this up and I
think it's important to talk about it in
the book because even though you know in
this conversation we're focused on
mental illness pretty quickly you
realize wow this is at the center of so
many other things this is so many this
is at the center of homelessness of
crowding of the Jails of problems in
schools of just a huge number of issues
I was with some folks yesterday from the
child welfare system just stunning how
you know 35% of the kids in the child
welfare system are not going to graduate
from High School why is that a lot of
them have untreated mental illness that
just don't end up getting the services
they need so it's it's really I think
for so many of the issues we care about
um this has been the piece that we just
haven't really addressed and haven't
wanted to deal with but we're going to
have to I call this in the book I call
it our Jim Crow moment because it is it
does these are are Untouchables in a way
they're our lowest cast they've been
neglected entirely and yet um it's it's
not who we are or maybe it is who we are
but it's not who we want to be and I
think it's you know what I'm arguing is
that um we could redefine the nation
over how we help those who are suffering
the most and who have the greatest
needs hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank you